- Good morning.
I'm Jim Levinsohn,
Dean of the Yale Jackson
School of Global Affairs.
I'd like to welcome everybody,
and of course, a special
welcome to the president.
President Arce's lecture
is our annual Sunrise Foundation Lecture,
funded by the Sunrise Foundation.
The lecture features prominent speakers
who come to speak on themes
related to political
and or economic issues
in emerging markets.
And the Sunrise Foundation
also provides fellowships
to deserving graduate
students here at Yale,
from emerging markets enrolled
at the Jackson School.
The title of President Arce's talk is,
"Emerging Economies in Latin America,
the Bolivian Economic Model."
President Arce has been
president since November of 2020.
He has served in the
Bolivian public service
for the entirety of his career,
beginning with the
Central Bank of Bolivia.
He has served as minister
of economic affairs
and public finance under Evo
Morales for almost 14 years.
As minister, he successfully
managed the Bolivian economy
in a period of unprecedented
growth and poverty reduction.
From 2006 to 2011, GDP grew by
an average of 4.6% per year,
peaking at 6.8% in 2013,
and, quite impressively, at the same time,
unemployment decreased, inflation fell,
and poverty was dramatically reduced.
A pretty incredible record.
He was elected president
in October of 2020,
with the majority of the votes.
I will note with special pride,
and I speak here for both,
Professor Caliendo and myself,
President Arce has also
taught economics and finance
at various universities.
Today's talk will be moderated
by Professor Lorenzo Caliendo.
Lorenzo is the Won Park Hahn
Professor of Global Affairs,
and also holds professorship
at the School of Management.
Lorenzo serves as Jackson's deputy dean,
and is himself from Uruguay.
So, Lorenzo will start
us off with some talk,
some questions, and then we'll open it up.
I also wanna extend a welcome
to those who are joining us,
as this is being live streamed
to many, many around the world.
President Arce, thank
you so very, very much
for joining us here at Yale.
Lorenzo.
(all applauding)
- After that introduction, I think it's...
President, why don't you
actually give your talk.
You were thinking about
actually talking in the podium,
or you wanna do it sitting from here?
- I think there is--
- That's great. So, Why don't
you start, please? Thank you.
- Thank you.
Well, good morning to everybody.
I'm very happy to be here.
Professor James, to be in university,
I will always have
followed all the writings
that he has done, and all
the research that he has.
So, for me, it's a pleasure
to be here in this university.
I would like to start,
just, because, I think,
the time is the worst
that we have in the world.
So, I would like to
talk very briefly about
what our model is?
The principles, the basics.
And also, it is very
important for us, the results.
In the both fields,
economic and socio results.
Which is very important, because,
at the moment we create this model in 2005
with Professor Carlos Villegas,
who was working with me at
the university at the time.
We have to fight with
the neo-liberalism model,
who was in place in Bolivia for 20 years,
since 1985 to 2005,
20 years of neo-liberalism in Bolivia.
And there were no model...
There were no alternative models to face,
or to replace the neo-liberalism model.
So, when we started to do that,
it took many years to develop this.
We have to face many problems,
and you will see a graph,
which we will compare
the neo-liberalism model
against our model,
where the most important difference is
and results of each one.
So, I will start, very briefly,
talking about the basics of our model,
which we call Economic Social
Communitarian Productive Model.
And we have to put it those words,
because it's a very long name for a model,
but it is important to say that at a time,
we have to emphasize
that the economic policy should be,
and is always a social issue.
Economics is mainly social science,
because we have to solve
the problems of people,
and the neo-liberalism
model, the market models,
don't take into account, many
times, the social issues.
So, that's why we call it
Economic Social Communitarian
Productive Model.
And also, communitarian,
because we recover from the
indigenous people, the principles,
as solidarity and other
principles and values
that the indigenous peoples have,
and survive to the
neo-liberalism in my country.
And productive, because we are changing
the Bolivian people mind,
because we would like to
become a productive country,
rather than only trade, or only services.
We would like to have
a productive country,
which is another way to do it.
So, that is the basics of
what we put that long name.
And the basics is that
a country should grow based on
the natural resources a country has,
getting economic exigence from them,
and which is very important,
because we are the antithesis
of the Natural Resource Curse Theory.
You remember in your lectures.
And we demonstrate to everybody that
a country who has natural resource
can develop based on
the natural resources,
which is very important for us.
That's why at the
beginning of our government
with President Evo Morales,
we put in place the
nationalization of hydrocarbons
and other resources, that now
under the new constitutions
is under control of the state.
That's the main issue there.
Secondly, we generate economic surpluses,
exigence, we call it.
In order that the state appropriates of
this exigence, this surplus,
and why the state has to be here,
and that's the big issue at that time.
I think, still in many countries,
the debate that if market economy
or the state in the economy,
we sorted this problem in 2006,
because we were a point that
the state has to be in the economy.
It's a very important role of the economy,
has to be related to the
state and not to the market,
because the market, it's not
equilibrium in the market,
and normally there's no
equilibrium in the market.
And normally, in the
market are two players,
offers and demanders,
but one of them is always winning.
It's not an equilibrium in that market.
So, for us, it's very important
that the state has to be,
it has to appropriate it,
to get the surplus of the economy,
in order to do the third
basic of the model,
which is, redistribute.
The principle role of the state
has to be to redistribute it,
because we are facing now,
and there are many books,
Mr. Picket is doing a good job there,
trying to understand the
inequality in the world,
but who's going to resolve
the inequality, the market?
No, from our point of view,
the market never will solve the problem.
Who's going to be the
solver of the problem,
is, of course, the state.
So, generate surpluses, exigence,
the state appropriates
it and redistribute.
Why?
We would like to redistribute
income surpluses in the economy,
because we were to resolve
the inequality and the poverty
that we were facing in 2005.
So, that's the principles. It's very easy.
When
you look at models, and
Professor Tobin shows us
in a very good manners in many researches,
but the models have to be very
simple in order to succeed,
and the principles of our
model, as you can see,
it's very easy.
To generate exigence
from the natural resources in my country,
redistribute it among people by the state,
to resolve the problem of
poverty and inequalities.
That's it.
That's the model in a very
easy way and very short way.
That's the way our model works.
On the left hand side, we
have the natural resources.
We have hydrocarbons, mining, electricity,
all the strategic sectors.
We get the money from those sectors
in order to redistribute them.
The state is in the middle of it.
Receives the money on the surpluses,
and do the redistribution process.
Not only generating a new country,
industrialized country,
with industry, manufacturing, and so on,
generate income, employment, and so on,
but also, as you can see
in the bottom of the graph,
you see the income redistribution
and poverty reduction process,
which comes from the income,
the resources that we
generate in the surpluses
from the natural resource, that's it.
It's very simple, the
principles that our model has.
And in this one,
you have some of the differences
with the neo-liberalism model,
which was in place in Bolivia since 1985,
as you can see it, up to 2005.
In the right hand side of the graph,
you see the Economic Social
Communitarian Productive Model,
which was two phases of it.
One from 2006 up to November, 2019,
which we suffer a coup d'etat in Bolivia.
The neo-liberalism model came again,
wrongly, from my point of view.
And then when we restart
our model in November, 2020,
when I become the president of my country.
We restarted, and of course,
we have a good results,
we will see later on.
But those are the principle differences.
The first one is the most debated one,
which is the free market
against the active presence
and participation of the
state in the economy.
That's the debate.
It's a long story.
In economics, it's a
long story about that,
but in our case,
in a less developing country,
where we have a many indigenous
people, poverty, inequality,
non-industrialized country, and so on,
for us, is a solution that the state
can resolve this problem,
and that's what we have done so far.
One of interesting things is
that the neo-liberalism model,
and now every time that we are looking at
every year is less dependent, but,
at the beginning, what
the neo-liberalism model
used to say is that,
in order to grow, a country should export.
We had a president in Bolivia
who used to say, export or die.
That was the beginning of the
neo-liberalism in my country.
And in my country, we
just die trying to export.
So, what we have done is to
change the engine of the model.
Instead to be the external demand,
should be the internal demand.
We should base the growth on people,
because people need to
get better life every day,
become better days for everybody,
and that is consumption that's
investment in a country,
not working for other countries.
So, those are principles, I
would say, more important,
in order to resume the
main ideas of the model.
Now,
we turn in some results that
many of them, of course,
are in the IMF, World Bank report,
and many international institutions.
The first one is the growth rate.
You can see in the average
growth rate from 1985, 2005,
it means the neo-liberalism model,
the growth rate was 3% in average.
And in our government, and
it's the first government,
2006 and 2019,
4.7%, we increase very
clearly the growth rates.
And of course, here 2019,
and 2020, about the COVID-19 and so on,
the pandemic and so on,
affected, of course, all the countries,
and it is the reason we have
a decreasing for 8.7% growth.
So,
we were one of the countries
in South America that have
the worst economic
performance at the time.
When the neo-liberalism model
came again in the government
who give the coup d'etat in Bolivia.
Now, we are increasing at 4%,
is the growth rate
estimated for this year,
and I think we can do that better.
We will see it, what we have done.
Another thing is that
many times, for six times,
we have it put it in the screen now,
but Bolivia was, in six times,
the first growth economic
rate in the region.
Some of them were 2014, 2018.
But of course, if you just look at 2020,
when neo-liberalism came again to Bolivia,
we were almost the last
one in growth rate,
but with a negative one.
So, it means that our model
used to have better results
than when we were in the
neo-liberalism, okay.
And this is very important,
we divided the growth rate in Bolivia,
for the source of this growth rate.
If you look at the blue bar,
it is the internal demand,
which this graph shows you,
that the internal demand is very important
to give us the growth
rates, which it means,
internal demand means consumption,
means investments in my country,
which are the main issues
that are driving the growth in my country.
Which is very clear with our model,
the theoretical issue of the model,
the internal demand is
driving the growth rate,
not the external demand, which
is the exports minus imports,
which is the external demand,
which is also negative for
us and many, many times.
And in those years where we
benefit from the exports,
of course, it works together,
the external demand,
plus the internal demand
succeed in increasing
the Bolivian economy.
This another one shows very
important thing for us,
because at that time,
everybody look at our
government as a socialist one,
and everybody is scared
about the socialism.
And they say, socialists
will take off from you
all your goods and so
on, and there will be no
private enterprises,
because the socialists,
what they want is to keep
everything for the state
and no private enterprises at all.
That's what they used to say,
and this graph shows you
that in our government,
under our model, the
private sector increase
much more than they even did
in the neo-liberalist model,
which of course, shows you very clearly
that is absolutely compatible
with the private sector,
because it's very easy to understand that.
When the public sector invest,
it is like a train,
that all the cars afterwards
are pulled by the state.
Everybody, when the state invests,
there is a multiplier impact
in other sectors, private sectors,
and that's why you have the impact.
If you look at 2005,
only 64,000 private enterprises
where were in Bolivia,
and now we have more than 355,000
private enterprises working in my country.
So, it is very clear that
we have an impact also
in the private sector with our model.
The per capita GDP,
which is very important.
We started in 2005 with
only 1,000 U.S. dollars
per capita income.
Now, we are 3,437 U.S. dollars.
So we multiply by three,
per capita GDP in our country,
which is very important, as you know.
The inflation is not a
problem in my country.
Even now, accumulate inflation rate
from January to August is
only 1.6% of inflation rate.
Even in these years, when we all know
that the inflation is
a worry for everybody,
especially here in
United States, in Europe,
they worry about what's going
on with the food prices,
with the energy prices and so on,
it has not worry in our country,
because we have the lowest
inflation in our region,
and maybe,
would be the lowest one of the countries
which has had the lower inflation
in the world, I would say.
So, it is very important because,
we are taking care about poor people.
Our model takes care of poor people.
We look for them.
I mean, we try to do everything
for protecting all the poor
people who lives in my country.
That's why inflation is the
worst thing for poor people,
because rich people, they
know how to protect them,
but poor people, they
don't have instruments
in order to protect
from the inflation rate.
So that's why we take
care of the inflation.
The trade balance has
improved in this year.
From 2021 to 2022 we
have positive numbers.
In the past we were
looking at negative numbers
in the trade balance,
but now we are improving
because we have a policy
which substitute imports,
import substitution, we call it.
The import substitution process,
we put it in place in November, 2020,
and has giving us good results.
We are improving exports,
but also we are reducing imports,
showing that the Bolivia has a big,
and enormous, I would say,
production potential that we
are using now in order to reach
these figures, as you
can see in the graph.
Savings and a number of
deposits is very important.
Look at the flat savings
in the financial system,
in the neo-liberalism model,
you have in the graph here,
in the left hand side graph.
In 1997, up to 2005,
in the neo-liberalism model,
almost flat, the savings of people,
and the saving started to
increase with our economic model.
And we have from 5,000
billion U.S. dollar,
we have now 31,000 billion.
So, we have a lot of
increase in the saving.
People have more money,
that's what they say.
And also in the right hand side graph,
you see the increase of the loans.
Sorry, the number of accounts.
It's very important, this number of...
We started in 2005 with 1,900
of accounts in my country,
and now we have more
than 14,000 of accounts.
It means that more people now have more
deposits at the banks,
which is very important
in developing countries,
because it means that not
only they have money now,
but the income they have
is more than the expenditures they have,
so they have a margin of saving.
And those savings now are
increasing in the deposits,
and in the number of accounts as well,
which is very important.
And when we divide it,
we would like to see if
the number of accounts and the money
that is getting in the bank
belongs to rich people or poor people.
We look at, when we divide it,
the right hand side graphic,
the people that has less than $500
deposited in the banks, and so on,
had more than 5,000 U.S.
dollars deposited at the banks.
And you will see that
87% actually in Bolivia
of the accounts belong to people
who have only 500 U.S. dollars
or less deposited at the banks.
So, it means that we have democratized
also the economy, the money,
now they have accounts,
and more people they have
accounts now at the banks
are people that have less
resources, less income.
That is very important, because
it shows some of the results
of the redistribution
model that we put in place.
The loans, the financial system loans,
also increase, as you can see.
And the non-performing
loans are very, very low,
comparing with what had happened
in the neo-liberalism period.
So, if you look at 1997, 2008,
even we have 16% of non-performing loans,
but now we have only 2%
of non-performing loans,
even in a period where
we faced the pandemic,
and everybody used the savings
at the banks in my country,
and also they didn't have money,
and so they didn't pay the
debts, the loans at the banks,
because they didn't
have money at that time.
So, even though,
we have only 2.2% of
non-performing loans in my country.
Also, this is very important,
the Bolivianization process.
In the neo-liberalism model,
Professor Jeffrey Sachs,
who was the advisor of that government
at the beginning of the
neo-liberalism model,
put in place a dollarization
process, in order to face
the hyperinflation we
suffer in 1982 to 1984,
where we look at an
inflation rate of 21,000%,
21,000% of inflation, of
annual inflation rate.
So, when we became government in 2006,
we started to do many policies,
in order to digitalize the economy,
and we succeeded, as you
can see in the graph.
In the past, in the neo-liberalism model,
only 5% in the financial system
were deposits in our domestic currency
which is in Boliviano.
But now we have 85% of people
is depositing money in domestic currency.
And also in the loans, in
the neo-liberalism model,
7% of the loans were made
in domestic currency,
and now, 99% of the loans
are made in our currency,
demonstrated the confidence
of people in our currency
and our policy, and in all the results
we were getting from our model.
And now, we don't have problems
with dollarization in the economy.
We are doing very well, and people
trust in our domestic currency,
which is for monetary
policy, very important.
If people don't trust in your current,
you cannot do any
monetary policies at all.
So, it is very useful for us to recover
the monetary policy from
the dollarization process,
that the neo-liberalism did in the past.
Of course, Professor Sachs now
is not a neo-liberalist professor,
has changed his mind,
fortunately, I would say,
but, at the time,
he advised this kind of
dollarization process.
The global and current
fiscal balance gets better.
If you look in the neo-liberalism
process, all negative.
We have more or less
nine years of surplus,
and then we started to have,
again, a fiscal deficit.
We were recovering from
that, and then, again,
the coup d'etat came in my country,
and started to do bad,
wrongly economic policies.
Again, we have almost 13% of
the GDP as fiscal deficit.
It's enormous one.
And we started to reduce it.
Now, we are looking to have
eight and 7%, and so on.
All these years, we are going to recover
those figures in this fiscal balance,
but, you know, you can see it easily,
what happened in the fiscal sector.
It is very important here.
Since we have put in place the
economic social communitarian
productive model
in my country, which is our model.
We changed the source of funding
of our public investment.
In the past, the public
investment came from
mainly external resources,
debt, external debt, basically.
Now, two thirds of the
investment, the public investment
in my country come from
the internal resources.
And you can
ask yourself, what's going on?
Why we changed the source of
the funding of the investment,
the public investment in my country.
And the reason is that when you recover
your natural resources, you have money.
That money that in the
past were going out away.
We keep the money in my country,
and started to invest the money
that came from the natural resources.
That's why, in a huge change
in the percentage of funding
or the source of the funding
of the public investment.
Public investment, by the way,
is one of the key issues in our model,
it comes from the neo-liberalist model,
where the base of the
neo-liberalism model is, of course,
the private investment.
In our model, the state
is the main actor there,
so, the public investment
is the main issue for us,
that's why it changes,
we invest more as a public sector,
and we have results as you see.
And that's why, because we recover
all the natural resources, and so on,
we recover the source of
funding our investments.
The medium and long term public debt
is not a problem in my
country since our model.
But in the past, as you can see,
you have the ratio,
external debt against GDP.
You can see that in the past,
there were many years that
this ratio were more than 50%,
but since our government, since our model,
we changed it, we reduced it,
because we increased
the denominator of the ratio,
and reduced
the ratio,
and now we have only 28% of the ratio
between external debt against GDP.
So, we were more comfortable now,
with the figures, macroeconomic
figures, as you can see.
We increased the national minimum wage.
In Bolivia, we have a
minimum wage for everybody.
Nobody has to earn a salary,
a wage,
less than that.
Yeah, and here, I think we
have in U.S. dollars, yes.
If you look at 2005, 54 U.S. dollars,
it was the minimum salary in my country.
And now we have more
than 323 U.S. dollars.
So, in this time, we have increased a lot,
the minimum wages in my country,
so people is getting more money.
And if you look at the figure,
and comparing the figure
between our country, Bolivia,
in 2005,
we used to have the lowest minimum wage
in all South America,
and now we are just in the middle.
And if we continue with this model,
I think we will getting
better year by year.
The unemployment rate is
also a success for us.
We used to have 8%,
almost 9% of unemployment.
In our government we applied our model,
we have more or less 4%, 4.4%, 4.2%.
And, now we have 5.2,
but in 2020, we had 12%
of unemployment rate
under the pandemic.
It was very, very worry about that.
But in any case,
unemployment is also a variable
that shows you that we
have improved a lot.
And, still, there are some
job to do in this variable,
but, I think, we will succeed
also in reducing unemployment.
Also, when we look at the social results,
we have here, how we
reduce extreme poverty,
and how we compare it with all
the South American countries
did in the same period.
In the left hand side graph,
you will see that we
receive the country with 38%
of extreme poverty in my country,
and we reduced it up to 11% last year.
Even last year we reduce it much more
than we did in the past.
So it means that the
model is working again.
And when we compare our results
with all the other
countries in South America,
that, of course, all the countries
are trying to reduce the poverty as well,
you compare it, Bolivia reduce
more than everybody in our region.
We reduced in 27%.
Peru, for example,
reduced it in almost 12%,
in the same period
between 2005 up to 2021.
So it means that our
model not only succeeds
in getting good macroeconomic results,
but also has good social results,
which is an advantage of our model,
that the neo-liberalism
model cannot appropriate,
cannot talk about, because
they never reached both.
Also, the income inequality
by Gini Index, we reduced it.
We were a very inequality
country together with Brazil.
We were the worst in the region, in 2005.
We had point 0.60 of Gini Index,
and now we are only 0.42,
which is a huge reduction.
And, again, when we compare our results
from those that the countries
in South America get,
and, again, Bolivia reduced it in 0.15,
and all the other countries
reduced it less than we
have done with our model.
Taking into account that
many countries still
they are using the neo-liberalism model.
This is another very
important things there.
The structure of the social stratum,
the composition of people,
according to the income.
In 2005, 60% of people in Bolivia
were in low income conditions,
35% in middle income conditions,
and only 4% in high income conditions.
Now, when you compare, we have
36% in low income conditions.
We reduced it from 60 to 36,
and we have increased
the middle income people
from 35% to 60%,
almost we doubled the figure from 2005.
So we have reduced poverty,
we have increased the income,
especially middle income, and
this is not only our figures,
I will show you some
Word Bank figures later.
Also, we reduced the differences
between the richest 10%
people in my country,
against the 10% poorest
people in my country.
When you compare the richest 10% against
the poorest 10%,
we have a difference of
128 times in the past,
but now we have only 20 times.
There's still some job to do.
Yeah, we completely agree,
but we have reduced a lot,
especially in the rural area,
people who live in the rural area.
They reduce more, the inequality
among rich people and poor people.
And as I promised, here is the World Bank.
This is a picture of the World Bank.
They issue a report, where it says,
the income growth of the poorest 40%
of the population, who do the best
in order to reduce,
improves for the income of
the poorest 40% of a country.
And you see here.
Bolivia, we have market at the top,
is the country that increase
the income of the poorest 40%
better than any other
country in the world.
It is a World Bank picture,
it's not our picture,
it's a World Bank picture.
We, according to the World Bank,
we increased the income
growth of the poorest 40%
in 12.5%.
Peru did, let's say, 9%,
nine and something percent, and so on.
So, Bolivia, according to the World Bank,
is doing better in
improving the income growth
of the 40% of poorest
people in my country,
comparing with all of the
countries in the world.
So, those are our results.
And the last picture I have for you
is this one that is very important for us,
which is the expectancy,
the life expectancy at birth.
Bolivia, if you look at the,
let's say, the blue bars,
we have a 64 years old of
life expectancy in 2005,
now we have increased to 74 years.
And you have all the countries
there in South America,
but in the picture that is in the bottom,
you will see,
comparing all the increases
in life expectancy
in the region, Bolivia has increased
almost 11 years of life expectancy,
which is the highest
increase in life expectancy
in the region.
For example, Brazil
increased in five years old
in the same period,
but Bolivia did almost 11 years.
So that's why, I'll finish
it with this figure,
we say that our model has succeeded,
not only in the economic side,
but also, more important
for us, in the social side,
because if we have a more equal country,
we have a better country,
a better feeded country,
a better healthy country,
we will have more and better
results and a better society.
That's the objective, when I say
at the beginning of the model.
Reduce the poverty, well, we have done,
and reduce inequalities,
that also we have done,
we have reached with this model.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you very much, Mr. President.
I think that's a very
enlightening conversation
and hypothesis about
the Bolivian, basically,
I will say, new paradigm, in
terms of think about growth,
and, I have a set of questions
that I'm gonna actually gonna
start asking the president,
but I do want this to be a conversation.
So in the sense, if people have questions,
please, raise your hand, and
I'm gonna give you the chance
to basically ask a question.
But let me start basically first, and,
so, it's fascinating,
and clearly this is, the
data speaks by itself, right?
Thinking about what the new,
let's say economic model,
basically, that you have proposed,
because you were a minister finance
during this period, right?
So, with Evo Morales.
If you see the macro numbers
are quite impressive.
Lower inequality, lower
employment, lower inflation,
and at the same time, more resources
collected from the government.
These resources coming
from, as you were saying,
the resource based aspect of the economy.
So I guess I have questions about,
thinking about the long run.
So, how do you think about first lessons?
What are the micro lessons?
I'm gonna be asking that in a second,
but more thinking about the long run.
How do we, a country like Bolivia,
that really depends on
the prices of commodities,
so, currently you were saying about
the importance of the internal market,
but these resources are global.
When you're thinking about lithium,
when you're thinking about
other commodities in the world,
they're driven by global
supply and demand.
So how do we make this more
sustainable in the long run?
So, I'll give you an example.
Chile, which has been an exporter
of copper for many years,
they have basically adapted a fiscal rule.
A fiscal rule to basically
guarantee, somehow,
like a level of expanding,
that it's not fluctuating
with the commodity prices.
Another example is Uruguay.
No surprise I'm from Uruguay.
They also just adapted a fiscal rule.
We don't have a resource based economy
as the case of Bolivia,
and there's other resources
that Uruguay basically produces,
but we do get fluctuations
and commodity prices,
and that can explain a big component
of these macro imbalances.
So, I guess moving forward,
and I apologize for the question,
it's more a challenging
question, which is--
- A very good question, I would say.
- Sorry?
- I would say it's a very good question.
- Thank you. Thank you very much for that.
So, yeah, sorry. So, what do you think?
How do we generate something that's
sustainable more in the
long run, let's say?
- Rules not always work.
And what happened with
rules, and those kind of
ways to my eye, it's the economy
usually break down very quickly.
Because they are not prepared for
crisis like this one, for example,
and they broke the rules.
And those rules, for example,
European Union, it was
3% of the fiscal deficit.
I don't know
how they will work, I mean...
But, anyway, the better rule
is the rule that is flexible
in my point of view.
And,
in order to answer your question,
which is a very good
question, the long run.
In the long run, we have to industrialize
our natural resources,
we have to increase
the production of food,
the agriculture sectors,
we have to improve it,
in order to have no
import dependence at all.
And that's what we're working on.
If you look at what
happened in this crisis,
for example, fertilizer,
agrochemicals, you know, and so on,
went up, and everybody cried,
and food raised prices,
and there were not food
all over the world.
Everybody was looking where to buy food.
What we have to do is improve
the agriculture sectors,
to improve productivity,
to become less dependent
at least, if not totally independent
from the imports of
inputs, seeds, and so on,
because everybody is looking
for seeds for everybody,
and that's the problem,
that is the problem.
In my country, we started
to face this problem,
to do some policies in order
to avoid this problem in 2020.
When I became president of my country,
we started to issue policies,
we started the import
substitution process,
policies we put in place, and so on.
That is the difference
we have these results,
all the people that was
trusting on the globalization,
trusting on imports, and free market,
and those things that never worked.
Because when there is
crisis, nobody's your friend.
Everybody's looking themselves,
and that's why we are facing this problem.
So, agriculture.
If you don't have last
model cars, it doesn't care,
but if does care if you don't have food.
So that's the first thing
that the world has to do it.
In our case,
countries which have natural resource,
they have to naturalize
it as soon as possible.
And, of course, in our point of view,
according to the respecting
the mother earth,
ecologic development,
which is very important.
It's most costly, but we have to do it.
Rich countries didn't
do it at that moment,
we have to do it.
So, in our countries it's much costly
to become a developed
country, but we have to do it.
We have to develop all
the natural resources,
respecting, I say again,
with mother earth.
Then you have to invest in education,
you have to invest in health,
you have to invest in many things,
and that is the long run.
That is the long run.
If you have food, and you have education,
you have investment technology,
you have a long term growth rate.
- This is great. This is great.
He's talking about sources of growth,
and this goes back to the
textbook, "Economics Models".
So, human capital seems to be important,
of course, investment,
private and public investment.
And I guess what we're learning
from Bolivia is more like,
so, we know the ingredients, the recipe,
it's a very local recipe,
the Bolivian way of doing this.
Anyone has a particular
question, would like to ask?
Yes, please. Yes.
- [Man] Thanks, Mr.
President, I'll stand up.
My name is Tobias Sathe, I'm from Ecuador.
I'm a master student here
at the Yale Jackson School.
Thank you again for being here.
Congratulations on your economic policies,
the stability and growth that
your country has experienced,
especially in this post pandemic period.
And especially for your
focused and commitment
of improving the lives of
those that are most in need
of the poorest household in your country.
My question relates to a
various contrast perhaps,
between your foreign policy,
and your domestic economic model.
So, domestically, as
you've explained today,
is to prioritize improving
the living conditions
of those most in need.
However, in your foreign policy,
you do recognize and support
the regime of Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela.
Is this not to you an
apparent contradiction
to support a regime that
has been responsible
for the largest amount of human suffering
in our nearby history in the region,
a country that now 76% of Venezuelans
live in extreme poverty
under less than $1.90 a day.
So how can you gain to
support, in general,
improving the lives of the poor
while also supporting the regime of
Nicolas Maduro in Venezuela?
Thank you.
- Well, actually we don't
support any government except us.
Alright?
What we do have is good
relations with everybody,
even with United States.
We don't have bad relations
with European Union.
European Union and many countries
participate actively in
the coup d'etat in 2019,
but we still have relations.
Bolivia is a country
who always will maintain
good relations with all the countries,
that is our foreign policy.
We have good relations
with Chile, for example,
we have a huge problem there about sea.
Alright?
But Bolivia is always not supporting,
we don't support any government.
We have good relations
with the governments.
So, it's a difference.
We respect the auto
determination of the nations.
If they want to do what they do,
they want to do in their country,
it's their problem, not our problem.
We have to respect the
way they decide to live,
decide to do elections, or not elections,
or whatever regime, political regime,
they decide to adopt,
the economic policy they decide to do.
We live in a country where
there are many countries
that still they're applying,
and their university
are still teaching the
neo-liberalism model,
and we respect that.
I mean, it's a way.
It doesn't means that we support them.
I think we have to live in a world
where we have to respect each other.
That's the best way, I would say,
to live in peace with everybody.
- Thank you, Mr. President.
Let me ask a question, going
back to your presentation.
And we can ask someone else basically,
who wants to ask a question.
So, I guess, something that
was quite surprising to me
was in the model that has been working,
let's say, in Bolivia,
this idea of taking resources
from what used to be
from the private sector
now belongs to the government.
The idea of the resources.
Where do we get this resource
bases on natural resources?
So the question is,
but at the same time you were
showing a lot of firm entry,
firms have to be actually
going up over time.
So I guess, one would actually,
as an economist,
basically, maybe, will say,
in priori, one would expect
something on the country.
If it is the case that the government
is collecting rent from firms,
that will dis incentivize firm entry
and firms investing in the country.
So, how did this happen?
So, I'm thinking about learning.
Is it in different sectors?
How come we are still
generating incentives
for firms to invest and enter in Bolivia,
when at the same time you're telling us
that some of these resources actually
are now collected to go to
the government and the people?
- Okay. Well, we--
- We're looking for lessons.
- We differentiate.
If there is international enterprise
that like to come to Bolivia to work,
and own the natural resources.
- Like the land?
- For example,
or mining, or hydrocarbons.
The constitution says that at least 51%
has to belong to the state.
So we can make some business,
but in natural resources
more than 51% has to be for the state.
That's one of the restrictions.
In other sectors, tourism,
services, industry, whatever,
you don't have any limitation.
You can go to 100%,
whatever, no problem at all.
But for the natural resources,
we have a restriction very
clearly in the constitution.
- Very interesting.
Anyone else would like to... Yes, please.
- [Woman] I have a question, and if I may,
I will say in Spanish and English or--
- Yes. I mean, I was
doing in English, but...
(speaking in a foreign language)
- [Woman] My question,
I really appreciated you
mentioning mother earth.
I think it's a very important concept
that is not discussed enough,
and being Bolivia, such a rich
country in natural resources,
what has been the main challenge
to respect mother earth?
(speaking in a foreign language)
- I answer in Spanish or in English?
(all laughing)
- Let's start in English
and then we can maybe switch to Spanish.
- (chuckles) Spanish or English.
- Oh. You choose.
(President Arce laughs)
I think some people wanted to
hear in English also, but--
- Okay. Okay.
Well, of course, for
every developing country,
the worst problem that we're facing
is the cost of technology.
We would like, for example,
to produce clean energy,
but this clean energy, it is very costly.
That's why you always, in
the international forums,
we say that developed
countries should sell us,
we don't want that they
give us that as a gift,
but, they should sell us at
very low prices the technology,
in order to develop our countries,
respecting mother earth.
Because it's very costly to...
For example, roads,
you should, taking into account the cost,
you should build a straight road,
but in the middle you have
a natural reserve, whatever,
you have to go around
it, it's most costly.
And who will give us the
money for that? Nobody.
And everybody says in the world,
everybody has to respect mother earth,
but it's costly.
And it's much costly for us
to develop in this kind of circumstances.
But, I think this is the main issue,
the cost of the technology,
the cost of developing,
that the developed countries
should take into account,
in order to make policies,
in order to respect,
to avoid some crisis that could be
in the ecological surrounding, and so on.
- Very interesting. No, no, no.
I Wanna go... Yes.
I don't know which one. Let's do it.
(speaking in a foreign language)
Good morning, Mr. President.
(all laughing)
(speaking in a foreign language)
Super interesting.
Clearly very important question,
and definitely the answer.
I guess we have time maybe
for one more question.
That's okay, or?
- One more question.
- One is okay.
So,
yes, I gonna give the... Sorry.
She raised her hand before, so, yes.
- [Student] Yeah. Thank
you so much Mr. President.
(student speaking)
- It's a good issue.
In all the South American countries,
one of the huge problems is corruption,
especially in the public institutions.
We can find lot of cases and examples.
That's why we are very, very demanding
with our public enterprises.
The difference is that the state,
the different institutions of the state,
and the public enterprises,
we have public enterprises
where those enterprises
manage the natural resources,
hydrocarbons, mining, and so on.
So, we have created a ministry
which is in charge of corruption,
or fighting against corruption,
which is in charge of
all these institutions
that have to report to these ministry,
in order to clarify,
transparency, everything,
in the process of licitation,
sellings, buyings,
and all what the public
enterprises do in their activities.
So, it is very important, this issue.
So far, we didn't have huge problems
with the public enterprise,
because as everybody look
at the public enterprises
as the source of money for
growth, for everybody benefit.
So everybody is looking
at what is is going on
with the public enterprises.
We have a law that two times a
year, the public enterprises,
all the public enterprises in Bolivia
have to do a public report
for what they are doing,
show the figures of their enterprise,
they have to, twice a year,
everybody has access
to all the information
about the public enterprise.
That's the way we are facing it.
And also, a more practical issue,
when a enterprise or any public entity
wants to buy something,
we are introducing an electronic...
- Auction
- Auction.
An electronic auction.
So, it has reduced a lot,
the Ministry of Economy and Public Finance
report to me two weeks ago,
that we save money more than 300 million
using these kind of electronic auctions.
So, it's more transparency,
it's immediately,
because everybody, let's say
the state wants to buy paper,
we put in the Web, we want to buy 100
blocks of paper, whatever,
and everybody puts their offers there,
and immediately, you know
who who want this buying.
Immediately, very transparent.
So, we save a lot of money,
and we did a more transparent
process in my country.
We had introduced it in every buying
and activities of the public sector.
So we are improving the
transparency, which is very useful,
and is in line with your worry.
I think that's the way
we can face the problem,
transparency.
- Mr. President, thank you very much
for your talk, for your time,
and hope to see you again at the
Jackson School of Global Affairs.
So, thank you very much to the
audience and the questions.
(all applauding)
(speaking in a foreign language)
(Closing music)